今、家のガスが止まっていて...
オンズオフ。（・・・オンズオフ？）
ハハ
お風呂にも入れないんすよ　（はーはーはー）
ガスが止まっているから、お風呂にも入れないー
ガスコンロも出ないー
ライフラインが一つない状態
なんかできないかと思ったんすよ、家で
ガス使わずに俺が、お風呂に入れる作戦を考えたんすけど
思いつきました　（はい）
ドラム缶を準備しました
あと、ガチもんですからね？　（ガチもんだな）
一応、100Lまで水が入ります　（フッ）
中身が入ってない、ちゃんとしたドラム缶でございます
ドラム缶風呂っていうのを、よく見るじゃんテレビで　（あーはい、あります）
あれを実際にできると思ったんすよ、僕は家で
でね、今日はちょっと
家の中で、お風呂、作ってみようと思います！
家の中で焚火とかは、やっぱ火をね、そういうのは危ないと思ったんで
（煙もあれだし）
そう。火災報知器とかなっちゃうんで
カセットコンロを準備しました
俺は考えた。カセットコンロで、ドラム缶の下からこう、シルクがうまいこと調整してあの、
フッフッ（息吹）　（あ～！これの？）
そう。火を調整して、いい温度になって、俺がお風呂に入ると
カセットコンロをうまいこと、このドラム缶の下に敷いて、
水を入れた状態で熱して、
僕は今日ここで、お風呂に入ります　（おぉ～！）
ではいこう！　（下ろしていいですか？）
俺友達いないからさ、鍋とかする機会ないのよ。　（はははは）
こういうのをやってみたかったんだよね～
こういう感じです
これをセットすればいいのか
(ﾊﾟﾁｯ) わ、はあああ！キタキタ！
これでOK?これでOK?　（これでOKになるよ）
（これNGなわけないじゃねぇすか）
きました！きました！炎がこれで点きました
これで多分、火は点けれると思います
これでさ...　   あ、でも足りないな
ここに100キロがガン!ってくる （これがっすよね？）
別で支えた方がいいかな？ ...となると
ではこれで４か所を...　（あっ！これっ）
これいいんじゃない？　（はーい）
（もうちょっとこっち押せますか？　　どう？どう？）
あ、こっち出ちゃった。　（んはっは）
はい、というわけでなんとか設置はできました。
これでガスコンロはいつでも点けれます
（おぉ～！）
キタ！キタ！　（ちょうどいい！ちょうどいい！）
お～！これ！これ！これ！これよ　（ちょうどいい高さ！）
これを待っていた！　（素晴らしい！）
これでドラム缶の上がしっかり熱されて、お風呂ができるという原理でございます
♬～
よーし！こんなもんでしょう
僕がね、火をつけて、温泉じゃねぇ方だ
僕がね、今から火を点けて～お風呂の温度をね、上げていこうと思います。
そこでしっかりあったかい温泉じゃない方になったら…　（フッハッハッハ）
じゃー点火していきましょう！いきますよ？
（ガコン）
えっ？！　え、今いやな音したよね？　（今～）
外れた？？　（ヤバイ）
ちょ待て、ここで外れたら　（ヤバイ。ガスコンロを取る策が無い）
ねぇどうしよう... 　（ハッハッハ）
ねぇ待って待って、ヤバイってヤバイって。外れた外れた
待ってどうしよう、どうしよう、どうしよう
まさきとシルクで持ち上げて、　（はーい）
あじゃ、まさきと俺か。じゃなくてシルクと俺か
あでも、（まさきに）ガスコンロ？
（ガスコンロ？）
一回持ち上げてみよう。せーの
うっわあああ、ヤバイ！ヤバイ！
せーの
(横にっ！)
あ、まっ、わあああ！置け！
わっあっあっ（喘）　わハハッハハハ！
♬～
（すごいラーメン屋の仕込みみたいなその）
ハッハハハ！
今加熱が足んねえのかなぁ
まだ！
ぅお！ぅお！うぉ！お！　　ちょっと温かい下の方
ババンババンバンバン♪
ババン！！　（あー）
ハッハハ！
（お、あったか！）　温かいんすよ！もう　　（うんうん！）
俺のワンちゃんは、もう入れる水というレベルなんで
ちょっと早速入っていこうと思います。
じゃまずはちゃんとでもさ、浴びないとやっぱり、あ　　（あーちゃ！！）
これガチで、世界的な、もう歴史的な動画だから。
いきます！
（ジュッ）
熱ッ！！待て！！ヤバイ！ヤバイ！ヤバイ！アッ！！
待て待て～　（底が、底が～っ）
本当にダメな奴だ。待って、ジュッっつったもん
ババンババンバンバン♪　（あびばびばびば） ババンババンバンバン♪
あっ、うぉ～、あぁYES YES・・・
お、お、お、　　うぉー！
うぉー！あったけー！！！✨
待って、マジ温かい　これどこまで入れるかだよね？
いや、ここまでしか入れないんだけど。　（ハッハハ笑）
あ゛～っ！
あこれ、なんか俺、頭の中で、なんか過去の嫌な思い出が
あ、待って結構やばい...　（考えが安易...てか）
（うっ血するぞ！ここ笑）
うわ、もう出れなィ！！！
もう出れないよ！！！　（待って待って）
待てマジやばいマジやばい
っはっはーあ、はぁーはぁー（震え声）　（いいですか？）
OK
（はじめく～ん）
なんか俺ら、現代のテルマエ・ロマエみたいになってる。　（ハッハッ笑）
（あ、やべ！はじめくん君、抜けない！）
えー？！俺知らないよ？？待って待って！　（俺こっからどうしたらいいんすかね？）
待って俺どうすればいい？
（あはぁ～（ビチビチビチ））
え！ちょっと待って笑
♬～